okay hey there and welcome to this
week's Android developer office hours
it's just the two of us this week myself
Richard Hyndman and Chris finds I mixed
slacking off on holiday and Stefan Lynn
tonight is doing a talking Jomo today at
GD g Munich I'd like to say must be GDG
Munich followed by GG Berlin and there's
a hackathon implement the weekend and
then droidcon fell in on Monday Tuesday
next week so uh Moritz you're gonna be
there yeah also dried corn belly
excellent i'll see you there i'm heading
out for monday and tuesday as well
average to abilene droidcon before I
made a few of them the UK ones and the
Dutch runs but never seen Richard isn't
it the original kinda have a nice be
building throughout this year as well
yeah the last point was not very good
the last one wasn't really you can't say
that you never know who's watching
trying to help anyway as usual we'll be
talking about android development topics
and we won't be answering questions on
unreleased features things like that and
also as usual giuseppe has also joined
us hey Giuseppe let's see it and you'll
see of course header hey guys ok we
transferring some address if you've got
already those question reading ah so
it's a cameron from the US last is the
preferred HTTP way to do HTTP calls
still to use HTTP URL connection and sea
para nice and some flaky flakiness in
some corner cases and yes so since ICS
that sort of change from the apache HTTP
library but the referred way to do is
move from sort of apache library to HTTP
URL connection and that hasn't changed
since there's a good blog post by jesse
wilson from about two years ago which
tells why and explains the reasons and
so yeah but there's nothing much there's
not day to it really that that's the way
to go forward see the saab place is the
way to go forward right yeah yeah sorry
i don't want the world capture the the
situation but i've also got a question
about the URL connection
you can ask him in please do yeah sure
and we have got a also one of those
corner cases and the situation is that
when we do a post request whether you
are connection and we wait for a couple
of minutes like four minutes and we do
the next post request the request is
sent twice the server receives the
request twice only after those four
minutes if we do the next request really
immediately it's working fine but after
four minutes and in a window of like
four to six minutes it repeats the
request twice and after ten minutes or
so it works fine again is there anything
which we should take care of that's a
really strange one he looked on Stack
Overflow for that see for the PS is
suffering from the same issue and we had
that one person at the same issue but
the answers did not really suffice and
from what I remember httpurlconnection
uses a pool of connections and so I
thought I would love that medicine
flakiness stove queuing its bounds like
a book if it's a DB is doing this it's
nothing I can really think of no it is
it on specific API version we had it
from for that one upwards and we're not
sure about lower version numbers and the
best thing to do is file a bug on beta
android com and send me a link become
google+ not a look mm-hmm okay also is
there may be something related to the
regular shutting down and going into
sleep mode at some point or is that are
related see other for you have got a
sort of exception back saying no
internet connection or comment
acceptance cool but and if that was
happening so it sounds like cheering
going on somewhere where it's just you
put the connection for it isn't actually
far on the connection and then the next
time it happens it use a modern sense a
more thorough and baby weight sounds
like a book to me okay oh no I will
follow up on you will stick
or floor yeah that's good thank you does
anyone else from inside the Hangout have
a question okay it solves asking Alex
from Israel's asking how to turn off the
auto translate feature for comments in
the developer console yeah i saw that
just interesting why do you know what
the language is it hi this is only
something you see yourself right about
possibly auto translate feature I I just
tried to bring mine up but I've signing
with different account if it's not an
obvious option then maybe we didn't
think about telling you know but
strangers EADS an opt-in you usually
take saw one time thing isn't you you
put in your natural language then press
the button and also translates to
everything yes I'm gonna log in and try
it okay I'll get a question hmm this has
gone so she enza i feel as i write has
asked how do you earn the Google+ out to
the animatic gifts so how is it
something else to code them and display
them and so if you have a look I'm not
sure the actual sort of exact why they
do it but if you have a look at the
google plus and settings up and in the
settings at the bottom there's an open
source libraries section and the app
what they actually use a decode the gif
is listed in there so it's it's an open
source class which you can download and
use yourself and to actually display i'm
not entirely sure how they're doing it
but i'm guessing there's a runnable we
shall die some image of you or something
like that so yeah really but it's not as
you know is probably not an amount of
probably supporting the throne works
against to do it yourself but i say you
in a translation yeah you can turn it
off on a per current basis so you get a
little probably probably i can ask
question under the-- okay well as
everybody know hackers are working too
much on the
you smile because always on this matter
but this is a very important for us our
keys are working on some play store mood
and around the dual analog around the
web we can find that many many APK that
install a fake fake store I have a
developer to myself son son tour
Sciences trying to check on server side
so when when the fake went the Fate
market store return the result and this
market we know that always return
licenses the license it I get the
scienter and sent to the server and
compare it with the public key from the
back server from google panel this is
correct do you think that the method
that i am using it's it's hard to work
around war on the sign to check i mean
he's a good system emerged is there to
do the check on your servers if possible
and not only we give access to the
content inside the application once your
servers validate that the user should
have access to the content if you can
pass the sign message back to your
server then it means when you get to
this level of of security it means that
the hackers have to individually hack
your application as opposed to using
some generic acts that may work don't
have it to work especially on the
application they cannot use your
automatic LOL soft leurs exactly so then
they're working against you directly to
hack your application and then you have
control over big expectations to fix the
hacks and more heart new heart monarch
yeah yeah but this is the the hardest
for them to achieve the value of free in
your application or making application
free if they can make a lot of
applications free by with one hack then
I'll see that's not easy for them but
Richard that the the question is the
following
because to check the license and then
get back to the response a chat etc many
times depend on the distance between our
European server and the final customers
that probably is now straily okay please
take part in the license check roaches
so what is a what is the problem problem
is that i provide for the problems that
i would like to store somewhere the
answer the first answer of the license
check so on to the license check its
approval and I am sure that the same
tool is fine i would like to store
somewhere okay next time don't check the
license again and almost 23 second to
check the license it is it fair is there
any any kind of storing system that we
can use it to save the data safety
should reals it's recently against
storing data on android and you can get
to a point where again you're in a
position where the hacker would have to
hack your individual application quite
hard to get access to it there's a
recent blog post on the android
developers blog around how to secure
data of course if the user has root
access they can get access to the data
but then if it's encrypted and we give
you guidelines on how to encrypt it
though they'd have to unencrypt it and
you know then put a hack your
application to find the key and if you
use a salt as well and you store that
salt encrypt it as well and you know
there's a few different things you can
do to make it harder than out of a smoky
like vinegar right Beth and if you're
changing the key with each time someone
starts the app then it's even harder you
know there's a lot of things you can do
now but we did a blog post on it
recently about the this how to secure
the best ways to secure data run Android
but of course if you have a very
dedicated Packer who really really wants
to get access to that data then and you
know they've got the resources to do it
then they can do it on any system it's
not an Android issue it's on before
seeking issue right of course so just
make it as hard as you can for them to
get access to it but I have a look at
the blog post there's some very good
recommendations for and sample code for
quite simple ways to secure your data
which will make it much like you if
party for you have a dev the linker
probably
can put in check for me sure yeah it was
it was like three posts to go on the
Android yes Gregory is it would be on
the first page okay okay thank you I'm
trying to find the thing so I've got a
question if I was ever asked a question
in the moderator and the moderator the
chat if I would like to shira she's if
he's gone again juzer be he's actually
got I so stuck so the title of that blog
post was using cryptography to store
credentials safely on Android I haven't
got access to tbell it's all I'm fit in
the chat but using cryptography tutorial
safely Android answering what was limit
I who had a question about the drug
plans for Alex Alex for Israel's
question on disable auto translation
it's like you can't do it at the moment
just ease but replied when actually
automate the translations you you can
also view the users review in the
original language you can also set your
language yet yeah yeah there is an
announcement on the dev console yeah you
can basically said the translation to
which then you can do a review basis you
can see the original translation but you
can't turn it off globally for all
translations but I'll certainly pass
that back to the Google Play Developer
console team who sit and let them know
that you'd like to be able to turn it
off again yep Hey hi um when starting an
activity you have the activity options
we have this def bits video a few days
ago which shows you how to fade in your
new activity from someplace or from an
image traditionally select the mix
exactly last video and is there a way to
do that for fragments as well and
not really let's see you can manage
insane so you can book set
customizations on the fragment
transaction yeah so you could
theoretically get the view from the
fragment I call it fragment docket view
and then sort of hacking an animation
together that will do some it similar
you would need to provide an ID for in
animation so can you create an animation
which has an ID at runtime see oh
there's two versions of the methods for
my remember there's one which gives a
resource ID and one that has an
animation object no I think they're both
there are two methods but I think they
both require the ID ok I'll check that
in my case I think you can use the tool
to create an object for animation then
attach it to the view just animation
straight custom animation infant isotope
operated ok hello animation from a
resource I can't see we're doing it
you're right without them either those
were and I mean obviously passing in
your own custom animation would probably
solve this as you pointed out but the
API doesn't allow but yet mmhmm yeah
alcohol coming of away then ok always
I'll investigate because that's quite
interested in to public answer almost
definitely yeah wait but if you have a
fragment hold of you can't you do the
animation on it when the view changes
but yeah it later to itch it should be
easier to do that instead of packing
after the view is created or something
like that
like once on view created and then you
load the animation and insert it to the
view back but I want to have the same
effect like you fade up an image and
then the image is displayed in full
screen for example like in a gallery
like you would have it so you would need
the original location of the image in
the first fragment and fade it up to the
full screen fragment like activity
option that's pretty well okay yes
anyways and if no one's got question
also guessing moderator and so it's the
brigand I'm Howard Balkans I think from
san jose in California as a stir what's
the best way to check and see if you are
able to commit a transaction for a
fragment and before sort of being how to
use state loss so if you call commit
before and after unsaved to instance
prev med school you'll get a big section
back and so he's asking what the best
way to check whether you are past that
or not and and if you are save the
transaction and beata sort of committed
later so my original sort of fought with
this was if you want to commit the
transaction later anyway one lunch you
commit allowance de los and cut out the
middle section of the code just do it
anyway and but if you do need to do if
you do wanna sort of handle it yourself
and save the transaction for later the
best way we to do one thing to say it'll
flag or variable or something in your
activity in your safe bundle and all
reloaded on on restore my show little
Miwa regretting Chris it mavi visual are
looking so yeah good so yeah nobody find
a good question
look no web view inside a scrollview
billows context for you scrollview will
always start from the top of the web you
by itself love you inside a scroll t why
are you pissed growing view inside a
scrollview it's gonna be tricky you want
spur whether you're inside a scrollview
Bulow's from text views the scrollview
would always start from the top of the
webview making the text views above it
go out of the top edge i need that
whether you to show some starvation or
content is there any solution that's
right I think he's asking for the
webview to be non scrollable as it wraps
hmm if winky one has any more yeah any
more details on that I don't fight
understand the question you want a
webview below from text views and the
webview will always be making the text
fees above it go out the top edge now
once a fixed X of you on top and then
the webview but he wants to open to
scroll together or he wants to rate yeah
I think just try basically it depends
what you want to put in the webview
maybe if it's only text content you
could use a textview underneath and then
use that text you turn the HTML styling
on for that text view would be a good
option hopefully that would work for you
trying to avoid using a web view inside
a scrollview um yeah if you are going to
do that you're going to need to handle
the touches yourself and then decide
which ones to pass to the web view of
which ones depart to leave it that's the
scroll view layer and my guess is you
would just stop the webview processing
any touch fees at all so you der you'd
override the touch handler of the
webview I think that's Greg except in
the end reply and text you can actually
handle them simple HTML and so eat
things like paragraphs and strong bien
and those sort of things they all handle
quite nicely voice text view so the nice
and there's a static method called HTML
from
HTML which will convert your HTML
internal which Commission displayed by
text me and that's quite a nice thing
and it will eliminate the whole
scrollable content within a scholar will
regroup public yeah I think we might go
to post on that mix here's my handlin
touch events on some through different
layers of views what's the best way to
an action bar owner Donald fragment
tricky yeah Donald fragrance don't have
action bars fragments are supposed to
activity though yeah um I you unnamed
yonder feelin alright so chris says
thank you I was wondering who has no
name yeah I don't I do you just changed
your name is Mike orbicam so um yeah you
can implement it yourself yeah um I'm
not quite sure why would you want an X
marked the dialogue but it's quite
serious after you google plus does this
mm-hm so gain you girl why do anything
fancy yourself there's no easy way that
where is it good but if it's on the
phone like a post Sally's yeah when
you're in a post there is an action bar
on the devil you can't come find you as
well so you can have an activity stall
as a dialogue and there ya swing this
swings i'm a straight white but and it's
not really supported a search zone look
like unity seldom have a bad i gotta fit
cancel yeah yeah michael from austin has
ice terms are using bitmap factory
options in sample size so being able to
source sample an image sort of jeremy
constrains on a bitmap and so he's
trying to eat gif images he's wondering
once why it's not working and so I'd
look at this I look at the code and
there's some reason or another has been
added to the gift Dakota and I'm not
ensure the toy the reasons why it might
be a restriction on that sort of gift
Dakota we use but the option just isn't
even read and so as it's been there
since of version 1 i'm guessing a known
issue and it's just no sort of way to
fix it I'm not entirely sure they'd miss
my investigation and but the issues been
there in the book tracker for about
three years now so okay so I don't know
it seems quite a big one to miss but i
have no more information nice just what
i've had to quit looking the code this
one and so other ways around it so you
could be co cubed yourself there are
various image loading libraries which
you can use which don't use top android
built-in image decoded so this image
magic is one there's 11 lightbox wish
you can use which includes its own gift
decoder and so you could use them or you
could go the hard route and then load
the bitmap full-size then Chris fail
pigma and but that's prone to issues
remember II so the best way you're
better try and do your images and pings
rather than yes really so sorry I'm
going from more than I real yeah why are
you using gift Joe is asking what a good
ways to do assertions and debug code in
Android 12 but a few assertions didn't
happen teasing with Stefan's actually
talk on something very related to this
in Berlin to not in unit tonight I he
would be the guy to answer it he's a lot
of information on this so maybe we can
answer it in more depth in next week's
office hours when Stefan's back yeah but
in the meantime yeah pro guards pretty
good Fisk on stuff so you can set it to
source strip out individual methods so a
good way is you have your log drop the
log exception methods in android if you
can change your proguard config to strip
all those methods are automatically
she's quite nice and there's also where
you can do it around them so when you
build your under at others build
confidence generated and that was a
variable called ebook which gets set to
true or false depend on whether
laughs has been built in debug mode or
release mode and so you can wrap your
wrap any sort of a surgeon or debug code
in one of those if statements and then
it won't run on a release and you'll
probably give you use proguard the good
things that it would also get stripped
out as well so so far sighs yeah okay I
have a special requirement to get the
installation date of an application
which I install from google play I want
to get installation day from google play
with my own account how do i get that
good ya see when I read this I wasn't
sure if he was using an app or trying to
get the dice from next door service and
so there is no Google Play API which
again so i took it though from nap so
package info there's got a lot of
information about applications and so
you can get sort of have the package
info for individual apps from from get
package manager and so once you have the
object for an individual athlete and
give you a lot of information sort of
white installed it when you see first
installed and as all sorts so yeah all
the informations f as a variable called
first installed date and which will tell
your nails first instant has their own
in the chat seen any interesting android
news this week they want to talk about
cantil brands come up anything yeah
what's been going on this week in the
android landing quietly i think just
today we had the new developer console
stats and they were tuned at five
percent switch the android dashboard on
the developer console to show the steps
based on active users of the Play Store
as opposed to active Android devices so
Android devices hit two of our servers
they do check-ins and they also do em
yeah when people use the Play Store and
uh we believe that the Play Store stats
are more relevant for android app
developers you want to see the users who
will be downloading your applications
and those stats are also more favorable
terms of Ice Cream Sandwich and jelly
bean hitting close to sixty percent of
the market together on the Play Store
stat so if you are looking at building
Android application API 10 and upwards
is like over ninety percent now API 13
and upwards is kind of sixty percent so
it's nearly fifty eight fifty phone was
it was it okay yeah the point is I
honeycomb somewhere my bag Matt yes yeah
but we all see more and more apps going
soft ICS off words now which is M yes it
can save you a lot of development i'm
just doing it once using all the latest
features and doing a rope yeah doing all
natively I can definitely worth
especially if you think in 6-12 months
time all the f you're putting into doing
the gingerbread versions will be for the
most part not at relevant to you as
anyone pre-ordered a galaxy s4 and HTC
one year much really can all around and
that's for you as anyone played with an
HTC One for an s4 anybody seen any of
these devices mythical devices no not
yet yeah the plate with the one quite
nice it's very cool i like these makers
the speakers yeah they're pretty loud
actually good for you're consuming
snippets of videos it's pretty cool
would you consider getting one well it's
not so annoyed so it's hard to recommend
for me yeah but for somebody else yeah
maybe interesting that was like actually
it's expensive stuff I guess fools gonna
be expensive as well right after these
are top end devices I haven't played
wrong yet but I'm looking forward to
trying them out maybe Samsung will
teleport work on Berlin and you can last
year the Rattlers really solid it's
pretty awesome to touch it it's really
cool HTC have that build quality thing
denies that the hardware is serious
really good yeah I look at people have
said that that screens just amazing if I
ride up on the surface of the fun and
very high degree okay I'm not so sure
about the blinkfeed was called the very
first home screen thing which you always
have by default I'm not sure whether
that's really something i would like to
use I didn't really spot like yeah yeah
putting always the youth
and also I found it interesting the very
first thing you do on the device you
unlock it and you swipe away the clock
and this is a little laggy and the very
first impression you get it lacks and
that's very strange the other stuff
doesn't work but the unlocking swiping
away at the former at the clock over 300
watts of power management issue when
it's not there keeping the power right
now and when you swipe it's ramping up
those yeah 300 processes or whatever
it's got possible yeah okay yeah i mean
there's time to step brings in sanibel
is it right that's pretty awesome as
I'll see I love it yeah yeah okay action
launcher 155 says Yossi go action
launcher got one question left in the
moderator is it advisable for an app to
rely on shared preferences yeah yeah
does it use xml store the data
internally and developing an app which
stores data in raw xml file privately
few devices through an end-of-file
exception when the battery is removed
yeah I would definitely have shared
preferences it depends on Zeta EG store
on Mars Oh mr. mountain text faster if
you're all storing Roberts not yourself
I wouldn't use a shared preference I see
think he's storing I thought when he's
using XML to store the data but you're
right he wants us historians data in a
row xml file is he storing xml Vater
stirring rod see I don't know it could
see Jane preferences a keep as you point
stall yeah so if you're storing data
where you have it sort of key-value form
then your share preferences is great and
but if your story anything more complex
and unique soft compound objects or
whatever and Jason or an XML sort for
that is probably a good way to go and
with you storm or you could ye stormie
david chandler our own david chan has
been working on them an RM for Android
called storm so you can just a show
objects away nicely it does all your
data access objects for you if you one
final thing actually mentions using an
object Apple Street and that choosing
serialization which is generally a bad
finger anger and good for using past the
boy fossil with passing objects and
always output into some sort of text
sort of XML or JSON if you get to file
serialization
then that's my way he looks at stylist
events there's one last question
audience but at the end stylist our
rents are supported since ICS is it
possible to subscribe for events when
the user unplugs the stands from the
device is a very strange well i'm on a
system softcore back off than they are
so stylist events conference mass events
and an F of use so I don't think we have
a concept of it stylist been Luggin and
unplug though you just get the the event
through each guy's name up and down
that's my sugar yeah since four okay
we're about done does anyone else in the
Hangout have any questions before we
call it quits for this week no I just
want to point out that the Android
developer event on shows that the time
is 5pm set of 4 p.m. for Israel it's
it's in our difference bra thank you you
see what for this show today yeah side
right now cheers ok we'll get that
resolved that's because the u.s. changed
time zone two weeks ago and we were two
weeks behind and they obviously they
they actually do our they said I'll
shows up for us they haven't noticed
that we've caught up on Saturday with
our time zones oh all right I'll um
maybe we'll put back on in an hour and
apologize to people trying to finish
them thanks very much for everybody join
us today I will be back at the same time
next week for more Android developer
questions these guys my guys cheers